[Music]
hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so since i've talked about robots in
the dune series and the political
structure of the doom series it's now
time to talk about the benny jesuit
sisterhood now the bini desert appears
several times in the movie and their
motivations are explained somewhat but
not in any depth if you haven't read the
book series i imagine you were kind of
confused about what was going on with
them so in this video i'll explain it
after the fall of the machines which was
ten thousand years prior to the
beginning of this movie the benny jesuit
sisterhood begin to rise to prominence
because humans could no longer depend on
technology as a crutch the sisterhood
emphasized honing human potential and
they did this through selective breeding
and training many jesuit skills are so
advanced that much of what they do can
appear as magic to people who are
outside of their order
the bini jesuit order is interested in
the continued indefinite survival of
humankind and they believe that by
looking to the past humankind can avoid
mistakes in their future high-ranking
members of the bennie jesuit sisterhood
are known as reverend mothers
these sisters have awakened their other
memory in a process that involves taking
a deadly poison known as the truth-sayer
drug and converting it to something
non-lethal the agony of the process
allows the sister to unlock the hidden
genetic memories of her ancestors a
giant pool of wisdom to which she could
draw from
the only thing is reverend mothers can
only draw from the maternal side and
this is where the sisterhood's breeding
program comes in the sisterhood has been
carefully crossing bloodlines for many
many generations using the great houses
of the lands rad
house atreides house for conan as
essentially one big giant experiment all
in an attempt to produce the quizatz
haderac the one who can be in many
places at once not only would the
quizzes hatarac be able to look at both
the paternal and the maternal half of
the memories they would also be able to
look to the future and see all of the
possible futures
now the bennie jesuit have had several
failed male candidates for quiz at
tatarak but they have all died during
the spice change but they believe they
are very close with the atreides
bloodline now jessica paul's mother is a
bini jesuit down to the core fully bound
by benny jezree conditioning
she was told by the sisterhood to only
have daughters which is something that
the benny jesuit can control because
they can meticulously control their own
body chemistry but she fell in love with
the duke atreides and she knew that he
wanted a son and there was also
something inside of her that told her
that she could produce the quizat's
hadarac so she gave birth to a son and
trained him in the benny jesuit ways
against the sisterhood's wishes the
benny jesuit had hoped to marry an
atreides daughter to a harkonnen son and
the child born of that union would have
been the quiz that's had iraq who they
would have kept under heavy conditioning
and hope to control
but because of jessica's betrayal their
plans that they've had for millennia
have been thrown off a potential quiz
that's hadarack born too soon not kept
under strict benidez or conditioning the
bini jesuit had hoped to use the
quizzette's hadorak to steer the path of
the human empire because he could see
both sides of his ancestral memories
clearly and also looked to the future
the bini jesuit believed that he could
best point the way the bini jesuit have
also spent countless generations on
different planets sowing myths and
legends about the coming of the quizzes
hadoraq a messiah one of the places
where they placed such miz were among
the freemen in arrakis this is why in
the movie the frerman referred to paul
as the least son al-gaib the voice from
the outer world in the legends the son
of a bini jesuit would lead the freeman
to freedom but they only believed these
legends because the bini jesuit placed
these myths in their culture
centuries ago so to sum things up what
do the benny jesuit want essentially
control the benny jesuit believed that
they have the best plan for the future
of humanity and they will manipulate
maneuver and adapt constantly to achieve
their goals
they may have lost control of the
atreides bloodline for now but they are
pragmatic enough and wise enough to wait
thanks so much for watching guys make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinns ideas
[Music]